[Music]
[Music]
Curren exiles is an open world survival
game in which you use the freeform
building system to craft yourself a
village or city which you then use as a
base to defend yourself in order to
dominate your enemies you're going to
need to create a safe location a place
that you can store weapons supplies a
place which you decorate and you invite
your friends through the show-off a
place where your clan can gather to
discuss their war plans building is a
very important aspect of the game
because it is the main way to secure
your group's
Colonels has a really nice freeform
building system basically we've tried to
create a building system which is as
flexible as possible that means that it
allows you to to build buildings almost
anywhere one of the cool features that
we have is that you can build a house on
a mountainside if you want
[Music]
in order to craft higher tier items
players will need to create crafting
stations these are things like forges
armor making ventures woodworking
lunches tanneries we have a huge
selection of labels and decoration you
have tables and shelves and barrels and
candles you can craft gongs and horns
which you then you can use to signal the
approach of your enemies or to let your
friends know to open the gate
you can kill some of the hardest
creatures in the game chop off the head
and have that mounted on the wall of
your living room some of those
decorative pieces are also little toys
like for example you can place an
archery target that you can shoot at and
we give you a score depending on how
close to the bullseye your shelter but
all sorry another major component of
crafting when players start to get into
the thrall system they'll be able to go
out into the world and capture artisan
throws once you place for example a
Stygian Smith at a stage in Forge
suddenly you have access to Stygian
weapons because his knowledge becomes
your knowledge
you can attack all the places structures
depending on the tier of the structures
are attacking some weapons are going to
be ineffective
you can also craft explosives that you
can use that affect all tiers of your
mate when you plan your base you should
also make sure you have enough space on
an altar and you need altars in order to
unlock the religion path the avatar is
the ultimate expression of your
religious fervor when facing enemies
with divinity to someone an ATAR it pays
off to think on your base layer of
carefully when one of them steps on your
city wall it's going to crumble
they say home is where the heart is but
in current exiles home is where you keep
the hearts of your enemies
Oh
[Music]
[Music]